The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So I guess maybe the
lecture today is the one
that is going to have the
findings which in a sense are
the most surprising to me and
probably the most, let's say,
unconventional or that would
upset the most people.
None of these studies
are mine.
They're all studies
by other people.
But I think that together
they paint a
somewhat surprising picture.
A small family is
a happy family.
This is actually a bag of rice
that someone took a picture of
with the slogan, "A Small Family
is a Happy Family"
painted on it.
That's a picture from
someone's travel.
So most international public
policy has been predicated on
this idea that large families
are bad, and particularly bad
for children.
And the second one is this
one, that poor people are
unable to control
their fertility.
So that's kind of some of this
maybe slightly despising view
about what the poor can do.
Here you have the social worker
coming to the very
poor, dilapidated house with a
large number of children and
the mom saying, but I take the
pill every time and become
pregnant, and it doesn't help.
So that seems to me like a
pretty good summary of where a
lot of people are explicitly
or implicitly.
And what I'm going to argue
today, and not on the basis of
what I've done but on the basis
of a lot of work that
I've accumulated, is that both
of these statements are
actually wrong, not
mostly wrong.
But let's start with
the beginning.
Why does it matter?
Why do we spend time
on this issue?
And why is it important that
people get it wrong and to try
and get it right instead?
It's because these
kind of views
actually influence policies.
So the first example is the
sterilization policy during
the emergency period in India.
So what happened during
this period?
What was the story?
AUDIENCE: There was this huge
campaign for sterilization.
And basically there were lots
of incentives or hand
[INAUDIBLE] provided
to ensure that
people met certain quotas.
Like, various policies, Muslim
people were taken into jail
and then forced to
be sterilized.
It was just a very harsh
technique to achieve a quota.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
There was a huge, very fast
campaign for sterilization,
which was very much delivered
from the top.
7 million people got sterilized
in a very short
period of time.
If you're interested in reading
an account of the
emergency period in India,
there's actually a novel
called The Fine Balance
by Rohinton Mistry.
It's a whole kind of full
spectrum novel about the
emergency period, has some
horrific descriptions of those
camps which are based on some
of the accounts that people
have given.
So some of this, of course, is
people were given incentives
to be sterilized.
But people were also sometimes
given offers that they could
not reject.
So there was sterilization
that was not voluntary.
And, for example, people
traveling on trains without
tickets, which was a widely
accepted practice at the time,
were all rounded up
and say you get
sterilized now or else.
Widely unpopular policy,
as you can imagine.
Then when Indira Gandhi called
an election towards the end of
emergency, she was convinced
she would win the election
partly because that's the
problem of being all alone in
power, that you don't
understand.
No one gives you the real view
of what is going on.
And she did lose the election
pretty badly.
And it is, of course, hard to
tell but it is widely believed
that sterilization policy was
part of the reason why she
lost the election.
And, in fact, there was this
slogan which was based on a
pun in India, kick down or kick
out Indira and save your
penis, which is based
on the phonic
analogy between the two.
So that was a success in very
immediate terms and a very big
failure in a longer sense
because people in the rural
areas are pretty reluctant of
having anything to do with
family planning.
For example, there is this very
safe way of providing
family planning, which
is an injection that
is valid for 3 months.
And that's very convenient
because then you can
forget about it.
You don't have to remember to
take your pill every day.
It's not very healthy, which is
why people don't prescribe
it so much.
But it does have the convenience
of being
very easy to use.
And people are really not a big
fan of it in India partly
because they are wondering if
it's some roundabout way to
actually sterilize them.
Worse than that, and we
discussed that in the context
of immunization, people feel
that other things could also
be some roundabout way to
try to sterilize them.
And in particular because
Muslims were certainly a group
that was particularly targeted
during the sterilization wave
in the emergency, Muslims
sometimes refuse to take even
things like the Pulse Polio
drops on the ground, that what
do we know whether it's
something like sterilization?
So that's one example.
Another very famous example is
the one child policy in China.
So the one child policy
started in 1978, 1979.
Very brutally because before
that Mao was actually in favor
of Chinese people having many
children because that would
constitute a large army of
people to construct the
country and to be strong
and all that.
But then they realized that, oh,
we have too many people or
they believed we have too many
people and started the one
child policy.
The one-child policy, at the
beginning, was very strict.
So basically you can only
have one child.
The second child, not only the
parents get heavily fined, but
in addition the second child
has no rights, can't go to
school, can't get health care,
can't get housing, can't get a
permit to live somewhere.
So basically you don't want
to be a second child.
So it was very effective
in terms have not
having a second child.
But they had one consequence,
which you probably have heard
of, which is the ratio of boys
to girls in China is
completely skewed in
the favor of boys.
As of 1986, when Amartya Sen
wrote his famous paper on
missing women, it was 94 women
for 100 men in China.
And since then it's only gone
down and down, especially as
abortion became available and
in particular ultrasound
technology to figure out
the sex of the fetus.
So nowadays less infanticide
but more abortion.
So they've relaxed the policies
in a way that I'm
going to describe a little bit
later to allow in some places
people are to have a
second child if the
first child was a girl.
So what is interesting about
that is it means that actually
in those places the gender ratio
at first birth actually
reverse where people were more
likely to keep a girl than to
keep a boy because that give
them a kind of second ticket
for the second child and they
could always abort the second
child if she was a girl.
So that's, again, another pretty
drastic policy which is
not popular at all and had
a lot of consequences.
So those are pretty extreme
examples, one of them.
But most of the poor people in
the world live in countries
where at some level or another
the government thinks that the
population is too big and
needs to be controlled.
And usually it's done in a more
civilized way of trying
to make contraceptives available
to people, convince
them to use them, et cetera.
And an example of an incentive
program of this kind is the
ICDDR, B in Bangladesh, which
was initially a big site where
they provided control of
diarrhea diseases--
so actually it's ICDDR,B because
diarrhea diseases,
Institute for the Control
of Diarrhea Diseases--
in one region called Matlab
in Bangladesh.
And then at some point they
started in about half the
villages in the region to
provide a lot of counseling.
There was a woman who was coming
to every house once a
week or twice a month to provide
advice and deliver
contraceptives and deliver
injectable contraceptives, et
cetera, to both make
contraception available and
try to change people's view.
So this one is a more usual form
of what intensive, or a
more benign form of what
intensive family planning
policy can do.
So why is policy so worried
about the number of children?
It really comes from this very
basic idea that if you have a
pie and you have more people
who want to share the pie,
there's going to be less
pie for every person.
And if you really have too many
people around the pie,
you're going to have very small
slices for each person.
So it's a pretty basic idea.
This was, maybe not first, but
at least famously expressed by
Malthus, who basically explained
that there are fixed
factors in the world.
For example, there is
only so much land.
So because there is only so
much land, we can only
grow so much food.
So if we have large population,
we are fighting
for this restricted food.
Eventually we will starve.
Now, the advantage is that this
is a stabilizing force
because when everybody starves,
everybody dies.
And when everybody dies, there
is again fewer people.
So the remaining people
can again eat
whatever food is left.
And he cited as an example the
black death, which was a
plague epidemic.
So here's a poor person who
is affected by the plague.
It was a huge epidemic
in Europe.
If you have not seen The Seventh
Seal by Bergman, you
should see it.
It's about the plague in the
North and in Sweden.
It was believed to have killed
half of the British population
between 1348 and 1377.
And Malthus explained
that this happened.
Half the people died.
And in the following century
wages kept rising.
So that was, for him, an example
of what was going on.
In the book we discussed the
more recent incarnation of
Malthus' view and in particular
some analogous of
the black death.
What is it?
Suzanna.
AUDIENCE: HIV and AIDS.
PROFESSOR: HIV and AIDS.
So there is this professor at
the LSE, interestingly,
[? Avignon ?]
was also in England, who makes
the same argument saying HIV
and AIDS, of course, it's
bad because people die.
But people dying, in the end,
will free up productive
resources both because
people are dying so
that's fewer people.
That's not great because the
people who are dying of HIV,
AIDS are mostly the
active generation.
So it's not great to
lose those guys.
But the remaining people also
have fewer children.
That should be good for
GDP per capita.
That's a bit galling
as an idea.
And the question is whether
it's true or not.
So what is potentially wrong
in Malthus' argument about
this idea that we have a fixed
pie, there is only so much
land, we can only produce so
much food, and if we have more
people, there'll be less
food for everyone?
What's problematic
with this idea?
AUDIENCE: He doesn't leave
room for innovation.
So in the green revolution,
population pressures actually
spurred technological innovation
that boosted green
production.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
It doesn't leave room
for innovation.
So the first thing is when we
write down a production
function, we tend to write down
the production function
with a big A that multiplies how
much capital there is in
the economy, which multiplies
how much labor
there is in the economy.
So that's how production
functions.
The big A is these unknown
things that we discussed last
time when we talked
about education.
It's like the productivity,
the innovation,
et cetera, of people.
Usually we consider this A to be
non rival, which means that
if you come up with a great
idea, your great idea can be
used not only by you but
by anybody else.
So, for example, if I come up
with a new thing in the Green
Revolution then everyone
can use it.
So the mechanically, if there
are more people around and if
ideas tend to come in this kind
of random way, you know,
every morning during your
shower you have some
probability to come up with
the new seed for the Green
Revolution or to come up with
the concept of iPad or to come
up with a Facebook, then the
more people we are, the more
chances there is that one of
us comes back with an idea.
So this is a feature of all of
those models of technological
progress, that the more people
we have, the more likely we
are we have a good idea that's
going to benefit everyone.
That's a feature of
models that people
generally don't like.
They think it's a bit strange.
But why not?
At the end of the
day that's true.
And then there is the argument
that reinforces this effect
furthermore, which is the
argument you had which is in
addition, if we are about to
starve because there is so
much population pressure then
that puts pressure on us to
have more ideas.
So that gives us all the
right incentive to try
and figure it out.
For these two reasons, what we
should expect is when there
are more people around, people
have more ideas, and therefore
growth is also faster.
So there is a very interesting
paper by Micheal Kramer which
looks at that in the world.
So this is population growth
five million BC to 1990.
As you can imagine, the quality
of the data improved a
little bit between 5 million
BC and 1990.
And the data points in
five million BC are
a little bit scanty.
However, what he does here is
that he has periods of data.
So his first point is from
five million BC.
It's estimated, obviously.
Then the second might
be one million BC.
So that's a very long
period of time.
And then he may have annual data
between 1960 and 1990.
But what he does is for each
period he has, he calculates
the annual growth rate of
population in between one year
and the next year and regresses
here or plots it
against how much population
there was at the time.
This is done world wide.
So this is population growth
rate on population billion.
And what we see is the exact
opposite as the Malthusian
graph, which is particularly the
more people there are, the
faster the population growth.
And that's about linear.
So the more people we are, the
more our population grows,
which suggests that this idea
for fixed land is wrong
because that would go the other
way, that there's no
stabilizing force that brings
the population back to zero,
and instead it's the opposite
that happens.
So far, there has not been
really any evidence that the
Malthusian theory was right.
In fact, we have many, many more
people than we were in
Malthus' time.
And people are by and large much
richer than they were in
Malthus' time and eating much
more and healthier and having
longer lives.
So it doesn't seem that if you
look at the very short history
of the world you get so scared
by what's going on here.
And yet these Malthusian
arguments in a form or another
somehow never dies.
It always keeps coming back.
And interestingly where it
mostly recently came back or
more permanently came back is in
Jeff Sachs' new book-- not
the End of Poverty book that
we discussed before.
But he has a book called
Common Wealth.
And the subtitle is Economics
for a Crowded Planet.
So that pretty much
said it all.
The planet is crowded,
too crowded.
One of the main challenges
is population.
This, I took from his website
where he kind of
advertises the book.
"Stabilizing the world's
population is crucial to
ensuring peace and prosperity
on this
already crowded planet.
If we ignore this issue, we risk
a massive and unsettling
youth bulge, unbearable
environmental pressures, and
unchecked global migration."
So the "unbearable environmental
pressure," that
refers to exactly the type of
limited resource argument that
we can have in the
Malthusian world.
So what are the environmental
pressure that
he's worried about?
AUDIENCE: The more people you
have, the more green house
gasses we emit.
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
Say it again.
AUDIENCE: The more people you
have, the more green house
gasses you can emit.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So climate is one, that maybe
more people generate more
greenhouse emission.
AUDIENCE: Water because we
have a fixed amount of
freshwater that we can access.
But the more people there are,
we have to grow more food.
We have to irrigate
all of that.
And it's important that we
have access to clean
water for daily use.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Water is one.
There is big pressure
on fresh water.
And what's the last?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Energy.
PROFESSOR: Energy.
And particularly there
is only so much oil.
So until we figure out
something else--
and certainly nuclear energy
is probably going
to be one of them--
there is also going
to be eventually a
pressure for that.
And what's the last one that
we discussed in one of the
first lectures that
people also have
brought up this year?
AUDIENCE: Food.
PROFESSOR: Food.
Exactly.
In the end, food is back.
Can I ask you guys to not
do something else?
It's a bit unsettling.
There are too many people who
are doing something else.
I am pretty tolerant
with that.
But that's just too much.
Like, there's half the class
with computers open.
I'm assuming that about 90% of
you are checking some other
website or whatever.
That doesn't help my focus.
So if you are doing something
else, just shut your computer.
Thanks.
And so is there reason
to worry about that?
Indeed, what we do find that is
something pretty striking
is that the countries that have
higher fertility rate are
much poorer.
So here it's plotted in
the other direction.
We have the wealth of
the country and
the fertility rate.
It's a nice log relationship.
If we were plotting it in log,
that would be log linear.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: Is there any
investigation about why Saudi
Arabia and Israel are
so noticeably
removed from the trend?
PROFESSOR: So what
do you think?
So the first thing,
why are they both
removed from the trend?
AUDIENCE: They have higher
fertility rates than you'd
expect for their GDP.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
They are richer than you'd
expect given how
populous they are.
So how about Saudi Arabia?
AUDIENCE: Oil.
PROFESSOR: They have oil,
so they are pretty rich.
Israel?
AUDIENCE: They have
an existential
threat to their existence.
They want to populate more?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's a very good
way to set it.
They have an existential threat
to their existence.
On the other hand, it's an
intellectually very rich country.
They also get a lot
of support.
And it's also very small,
so that might
eventually create issues.
In fact, that does
create issues.
But that's probably the reason
why Israel is so much richer
compared to their income.
And the Israel case kind of
illustrates well the problem
with this graph which is you
could read from this graph
that, oh, having a large
population makes you poor.
Or you could read from this
graph that poor countries have
more kids or richer countries
have fewer kids in the
opposite direction.
That is, the lack of wealth that
makes people have a lot
of children maybe because
of people's choices.
Because when we explain Isreal,
we don't want to
explain why Israel is rich
despite having many children.
We want to explain why Israel
has high fertility rate
despite being rich.
So we explain here what are
the reasons why people in
Israel would like kids.
That's not the case in
other countries.
So that's kind of what
I'm saying here.
As usual, the correlation
could go either way.
We could find that poor
countries could be poor
because they are too crowded.
A rich country could have
lower fertility
because they are rich.
Maybe as people become richer,
the opportunity cost of their
time is higher.
As a country becomes richer,
women are more likely to find
things that they can do
in the labor market.
And therefore women are more
likely to participate in the
labor market.
And therefore, having a kid, you
know, you don't want to be
taking off a year of your life
every other year because you
are bearing or nursing
a very small child.
So it's kind of difficult
to answer this question.
It's not going to be solvable by
looking at other countries.
And it's even harder to ask what
population increase would
do to the planet.
It might be right even
if Malthus was wrong.
The [INAUDIBLE] might
still be right.
It might be right that we will
never find a solution to get
clean water access to everyone,
especially if it's a
much larger group of people.
It might also be wrong.
But it's difficult to know.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: Is there a correlation
with religion in
fertility at all?
PROFESSOR: I would assume so.
I don't know which
way it is though.
It used to be that Catholic
country would
have a lot of children.
And now it's not true anymore.
The countries that have the
fewer children in Europe are
the traditionally Catholic
countries
like Italy and Spain.
So actually I think there is a
correlation, and I don't even
know what it is.
Like, for example,
what are the--
but you're right.
That brings to the number of
children you decide to have,
et cetera, depends on
your culture as
well as other things.
So it's difficult to say
anything about countries.
It's even harder to say anything
about the world.
So we can go back to our
traditional refuge and start
looking at the family and ask
whether it is true that a
small family is a
happy family.
And, of course, that's not
necessarily the answer of what
it would be for a country or
let alone for the world
because there are externalities
of a large
population in a country or in
a community or in the world
that the family might
not internalize
or take into account.
For example, having more kids,
the kids may still be as
educated and you may have
as much water to
feed the kids today.
But the fact that you have just
one more kid puts more
pressure on water resources
for everyone in the world.
So we are not fully answering
the question were we answering
this particular question on
what happened to family.
However, it's still an important
question because, in
fact, even if you where
convinced that family or that
large population is a problem
for the world as a whole and
you really want to deal with
it, even if you were that
convinced you would have
to find a way to do it.
And the issue is an effective
way to do it would certainly
depend on whether having a
large family is something
that's immediate costly
to people.
And therefore you need to make
them realize that, and then
they'll have fewer children on
their own or whether it's
something that's beneficial
to people.
So we need to answer this
question even if we are
interested just in the external
world wide effect of
large population.
Moreover, if you find out, for
example, that it's very bad
for children to live in a large
family then you could
want to design a population
family that would increase the
cost of having children by ideas
ranging from I'm going
to reduce the cost of not having
them by reducing the
cost of contraception to I'm
going to make it illegal to
have more than one
child in China.
So if we consider that parents
are not fully maximizing the
welfare of their children and of
the second generation then
we might be even more concerned
about a population
policy for the sake of the
children, even if we weren't
sure of what it would do to the
world as a whole to have
fewer or more kids.
So these reasons, that's a
question which is pretty much
immediately important.
And if you read Sachs' book,
Common Wealth, he's going to
tell you very assertively,
very authoritatively.
He's going to tell you that
large families are bad for
kids, that there is plenty of
evidence that large families
are bad for kids.
And that's not really
the subject I study.
So when I went into this to
review the evidence when we
were preparing the book, I
assumed that I would find a
number of studies finding
exactly this.
And, of course, when you look at
the reason we assume that,
well, that seems, again, pretty
much intuitive that if
you have a larger family, that's
more people on one
single pie.
That's fewer to eat
for everyone.
There's also a very, very famous
paper by Gary Becker
who won the Nobel Prize for his
work on the economics of
the family, which coined
the term the quality
quantity trade off.
And the quality quantity trade
off is exactly that.
Siblings compete for resources,
parental attention,
money, time, et cetera.
So if you have more siblings,
they will compete for this.
And, therefore, it's bad
for all of them.
So the paper starts from this as
an assumption and then from
this assumption builds a model
which shows that suppose that
the quality is a normal good.
So you want more quality
children
when you become richer.
Then as people become richer,
they will move on the quality
quantity trade off towards fewer
kids of higher quality.
So the paper's argument
was not--
the first one with the second
one which is given the quality
quantity trade off, we should
see that richer family have
fewer children of
higher quality.
So I sort of assumed that it was
a given that this quality
quantity trade off existed.
Now, another thing that if you
look at the data you do find,
as [? West ?] pointed out
earlier, that in general it's
true that children are of lower
quality in larger families.
They tend to have less
education, to be smaller, et
cetera, when they have
more siblings.
It's not even always true.
But it tends to be true.
The problem, of course, is we
can't look at that because
even in Baker's model he just
explained to us that because
there is this trade off between
quality and quantity,
the families where we are going
to see many children are
precisely the families
which don't care
so much about quality.
So even if we manage to force
them not too have many
children, they would still want
lower quality children
and would spend their money
on other things
than quality children.
That goes back to the first
concepts we saw when we looked
at program evaluation and this
idea of potential outcome.
The potential outcome, the
potential quality of the
children born in large families,
is lower than the
potential quality of the
children born in small
families, keeping the family
size constant just because the
people who have large families
in Baker and Tomms' world are
people who care less about the
quality of the children.
I don't know if that is right.
But under this model that
we are trying to
test I would be right.
That means we cannot look
at just the correlation.
More specifically, we
know that poorer
families are larger.
And therefore it is likely
that large family is
correlated with poverty, which
would make children less
educated for all sorts
of reasons.
So what can we look at?
We need to look at things that
somehow have forced families
to be larger or smaller than
people wanted them to be.
Or we need to look at policies
that made it easier or harder
for people to control
their family.
So what is a thing that makes
your family bigger than you
may have planned it to be?
AUDIENCE: Having twins was
one of these, I guess.
PROFESSOR: Having twins, yes.
And what is another one?
AUDIENCE: In some families, in
some countries that consider
that they really want
to have a boy.
Let's say their first
child is a girl.
They're more likely to have
more children because they
want [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Exactly, the
gender of the family.
So, specifically, before sex
selection was available,
gender was more or
less exogenous.
Or in places where people
don't do sex selective
abortion, gender is more
or less exogenous.
So if you really want a boy
and you have a girl then
you're going to have
one more child.
This means, by the way, that
girls tend to live in large
families, which could be one
reason why girls do worse in
life than boys, not because
people treat them worse once
they are born but because they
live in large families.
Now, another thing related to
the gender of the children is
that in a lot of cases people
want to have a mix
composition.
So for example in the US, you
are more likely to have a
third child if your first two
children were of the same
gender, say, two boys
or two girls.
You are about 8% more likely
to have a third one.
And that, again, conditional
on the gender
of the first child.
The gender of the second one is
random in the US, assuming
people don't abort kids
based on their gender.
Then therefore we can use that
to look at the effect of a
larger family size than you
would otherwise have had
because now we have two families
that are all exactly
the same, except one of them end
up with three kids and one
of them ends up with two kids,
either because of a twin in
the second birth or because
of this gender selection.
So of course with the twins,
we cannot look at the twins
themselves.
Why looking at the twins
themselves would be
problematic?
AUDIENCE: Because at the point
when the twins arrive,
there's, like, nothing to
compare it to, right?
So wouldn't it be more useful
to look at situations where
there was a single kid and then
the second child ended up
being twins?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you could say let me compare
at first births the
families which have
twins versus
families which have one.
You would compare two to one.
And why wouldn't we want
to do that comparison?
AUDIENCE: Can you repeat
the question?
PROFESSOR: So suppose that
I want to use twins.
And I'm saying let me focus
on first birth.
And I am going to compare all
of the kids that are born as
single children and all of the
kids that are born as twins.
So the twins are two, and the
singles children as one.
Is this comparison valid?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: So why?
AUDIENCE: Because isn't it the
case that we just talked about
the fact that it's safe.
If you get a kid, then
you want another kid.
Then you can say if I get twins,
then I'll have one more
than I actually intended to.
But if you want a kid and
then you get twins--
I don't know what the
expression is.
PROFESSOR: You mean you are
saying that the kid who is
single birth eventually
will have a brother.
So maybe twins at first birth
might not change the total
family size?
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: So that's true, which
is there might not be an
effect on total family size or
the effect might be very small
because almost everyone wants at
least two, in which case if
we go with [? Deck's ?]
idea of saying let's look at the
second birth and you move
from two to three, and maybe
there are fewer kids who would
want three, that creates a
bigger impact on family size.
That's right.
And there is another problem
with twins, pretty obvious,
like, direct.
You guys are over thinking it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I don't know
if this is it.
But the reason I think you
couldn't hurt the kids who
weren't twins because if you're
a twin you'd probably
get fewer nutrients.
So you're less likely,
especially in countries with
poor families, they're
less likely to
have the same potential.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
That's the problem.
Twins are fragile.
Even here they are born
with lower weight.
They are more easily premature
children and even more so in
places where the health care
might not be so good.
So twins are, in general,
weaker.
So if we go back to your point
and say, well, maybe the
family size is the same at the
end between a family that has
twins at first birth and a
single child at first birth,
you end up with three
regardless, say, or two
regardless, but there might
still be a difference between
the twins and the non twins just
because the twins were
born weaker.
AUDIENCE: Can't you
account for that?
PROFESSOR: How?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
If you have, like, data on the
average wealth of twins versus
the average wealth--
PROFESSOR: So it's not
only the wealth.
The wealth would be the same.
So you could adjust looking at
birth weight, for example.
So some people have done that,
to look at the difference
between twins and non twins
comparing for birth weight and
assuming that birth weight
completely captured the fact
that twins were in a more
adverse in utero environment.
But another thing you can do
is to do what was suggested
before which is to say, let's
look at that kid who was born,
the first one, and then at the
second birth it gets either
one sibling or two.
And that's a shock
for him or her.
And he or she is no different.
It's the same child and the
first few years were in the
same environment.
But certainly there are these
two kids who are coming
instead of one.
So that gives you a shock.
Yeah, Ben.
AUDIENCE: Isn't it also
difficult to look at the
relative treatment of the
children because there is no
prior child to look at?
But if we have twins in the
first trial, they're born at
the same time, they're
the same age.
You can't say one education--
the parents did something
completely different than they
would have done otherwise--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So knowing what they would have
done is looking at the
single child in other family
and saying that
getting twins is random.
So they would have treated them
like people generally
treat their single children.
But the problem is that probably
they wouldn't because
they are twins and they're very
fragile, whereas if I
look at the first child, the
first child is the same.
But then he is in a family of
three or in the family of two.
So there is a paper--
so we went over gender--
a paper by George Angrist,
Victor Lavy, and Eliot
Schlosser looking at exploiting
the twinning and
the gender differences, both the
sex mix and the fact that
people prefer boys in Israel.
Now, you might think Israel
is a rich country.
Why do we care?
Or we might care about Israel in
general, but why do we care
in this class?
Well, Israel is a rich country
but it also has poor people.
And they are using pretty
much all of Israel.
So it's very large samples,
including a large sample of
poor people because they also
look at the Israeli Arabs
which are getting to be as poor
as some of the people we
look at in other countries.
So they are looking at that in a
lot of detail, comparing the
siblings of twins, first born,
when the second birth is a
twin, comparing the children
born in different gender mix,
and then putting all
of this together.
And they find no effect at all
of larger family size.
They find absolutely no adverse
impact of being born
in a larger family.
That is a bit surprising since,
again, I think most
people would have expected
large effect.
So you can think, OK, maybe it's
Israel and even Israeli
Arabs live in an environment
where they are poor but they
can go to school for free.
They can get good health care.
So maybe we don't see the
quality quantity trade off in
this context because these
are Israeli Arabs.
So let's look at other places.
Well, in obvious other places
the one-child policy where the
state forces you to
have fewer kids.
So here there is a paper by
Nancy Chen, who interestingly
is a student of George Angrist,
former student, who
looks at the one child policy.
So that's pretty clear,
the one child policy.
Either you can have a second
child or you cannot.
And I mentioned that since the
mid 1980s, some areas allow
you to have a second child if
your first one was a girl,
which means that if you want a
girl in an area that relaxed
the policy, after the relaxation
policy was put in
place then you're more likely
to have a sibling than if
you're born a girl in a non
relaxed area or if you are
born a boy in a relaxed area.
So she exploits that.
And you're very much more likely
because pretty much
everyone who had a chance to
have a second child did.
A lot of people did.
So what do we find?
This is a graph that tells you
the number of siblings that
the child has as a function of
whether they were born and
whether they were born
in a relaxed area.
So this is the difference
between the family size.
This is the difference between
the number of siblings that
the girl has in a relaxed area
versus non relaxed area.
So not all the areas relaxed.
And the areas that relaxed,
the 1978, 1970s, because
before they didn't have
a one-child policy.
So what you find is that before
the one-child policy,
there is not much difference
between the number of siblings
that the girls have in area that
eventually will relax the
policy because there is no such
policy in other area.
So those places are
not fully random.
But girls have an average of
maybe 0.50 more sibling in the
relaxed areas before
the policy.
And boys have 0.50 areas as
well, which shows us that they
tended to allow people to relax
the policy in places
which like children more.
But what is interesting and
what's happening after, the
relaxation of the policy
only affect the girls.
So after the one-child policy,
you start seeing bigger and
bigger difference between the
number of siblings that the
girls have in a relaxed area
versus non relaxed area.
And towards the end of the
period where most places
passed the laws, a girl had an
average of about half more
sibling in places that
did pass such a law.
That means that every second
family who had a chance to
have a another kid after
a girl had it.
Zach.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't you expect
there to be a gap?
In the places that relaxed the
policies, didn't they only
relax the policies to have a
second child if the first one
was a girl?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So it's exactly what
you would expect.
So this is telling you that in
places which had relaxed area,
that did have an effect, that
people took advantage.
And if they had a girl as the
first born, they had a second
child, whereas for the boys,
since that doesn't allow them
to have when a policy, there
is no difference.
So you're exactly right.
This is exactly what
you would expect.
It's not an interesting fact.
It's just showing you that
the policy worked
as you would expect.
Now we're going to exploit that
to say is it the case
that this first girl, who has
more siblings, is she less
educated compared to what would
have been the case if
she were a boy?
So we are looking here at the
first stage, if you want.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So is this all looking
at the first borns and
showing their--
PROFESSOR: This is looking at
the number of siblings of the
first born.
So it's telling you that if
you're a girl, you're more
likely to have a sibling if
you're born relaxed than non
relaxed towards the
end of the period.
But that's not the case for
boys, which is exactly what we
would expect.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: Is all this data
from areas eventually
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So each of these
points is the difference
between all the places that will
eventually be relaxed and
all the places that will
never be relaxed.
So all these points are
already differences.
But the reason why it keeps
increasing is that it's the
difference between places that
will eventually be relaxed.
And some of them got relaxed
only towards the end.
And that's why the difference
keeps increasing.
Does that make sense?
So each of these is
a difference.
And it's telling you that if you
look just at this point in
1981, if you were a girl born
in a relaxed area, you had
about half a sibling more than
if you were a girl born in a
non relaxed area.
But for boys, you had only a
tenth of a sibling more, like,
strictly speaking, zero.
So that is exactly right.
There's nothing particularly
interesting there.
That's just the basic fact that
we are going to rely on
to now show we're going to run
the exact same analysis for
the first born, not looking at
their number of siblings but
looking at their education.
So if having more siblings is
bad for your education, what
would you expect the shape
of the equivalent
of these red lines?
It would be decreasing, because
the later you were
born, the more likely that
you have one more kid.
And, in fact, what do we find?
We find that it's increasing,
and moreover it's increasing
for girls but not for boys.
So towards the end of the
period, girls born in relaxed
area are actually more educated
than boys born in a
relaxed area, compared
to what happened in
a non relaxed area.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you help me
understand what the y-axis is?
PROFESSOR: The y-axis here is
the difference in the years of
education between the relaxed
and the non relaxed area.
So it's saying that the relaxed
area, probably we are
poor because the kids at the
beginning of the period tended
to be less educated in a relaxed
and non relaxed area.
And at the end of the period
it's towards zero.
AUDIENCE: So the more kids
you have, the more
education you have.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
The more siblings you have, the
more education you get.
Remember, it's not going
from one to eight.
It's going from zero siblings to
half a chance of a sibling.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So how much
more education does
that translate into?
Because if, for instance, you
have a first child that is a
girl and then you wait, say, six
years, so the child has a
year of school, which
[INAUDIBLE] haven't gotten,
and then you have a second
child, then you're still not
actually trying to educate
your child anymore.
You're just still investing in
the children that you have.
PROFESSOR: Can you repeat
the question?
AUDIENCE: I mean, if you have
two children, can't you say
your [INAUDIBLE]
goes to school?
Whereas if you just were
stuck with one child--
how do I explain this?
And really does this show at all
that there was the intent
to educate these girls
who were first born?
Or does it just show that they
were investigating whether
they'd have while they had it.
And then once they got a second
boy, they started
investing in the boy?
PROFESSOR: So if this were in
the model then we would find
the girls to be less educated
because once the boy comes--
or at least as much-- because
once the boy comes then they
start, you know, sharing the
resources or giving everything
to the boy.
It's good pointing out that
mostly the second kid is a boy
because selective abortion of
the second child is horrible.
Like, most of these second
kids are boys.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: So you were saying
that if you get another child
[INAUDIBLE] schools that they
actually get more schooling,
but with this school is that
they get just as much.
PROFESSOR: Oh, well, this is the
idea of starting from the
differences.
So the idea is that those
regions were regions where
before girls tended to
be less educated.
And even the boys tended
to be less educated.
And nothing really changed
for the boys.
But for the girls it went up.
So the point is these regions
that relaxed, they are not the
same as the regions
that didn't relax.
Those were poor or more
backwater regions where the
problem of infanticide was
bigger or accepted
[INAUDIBLE].
That's why they relaxed.
So that's why we are more
interested in the slope and
how it looks at the end compared
to the beginning than
the levels.
So the levels are wherever
they are.
And in particular what is very
interesting is that the girls
tend to do better than the boys
in the relaxed areas,
relatively better in the relaxed
area than the boys,
which is saying that if you
have to be a girl, it is
better to be a girl in the
relaxed area compared to being
a boy in the relaxed area.
AUDIENCE: I mean, it mean--
[INAUDIBLE] anything about
Chinese culture-- it might
mean that the parents that are
in these relaxed areas which
might be in more rural areas,
they want to educate their
girls more because they want to
then send them so that they
can find a husband.
If they have more education,
maybe they have more chance of
getting a good husband.
PROFESSOR: I think you're right,
except that this is
what it's trying to account for,
which is, let's say from
1973 to 1977 is when
the areas--
there is no relaxation because
there is no policy yet.
So this is saying that those
places, before the relaxation,
girls tended to do much worse,
whereas after the relaxation
they do somewhat better.
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
whether this can be considered
a good refutation of the quality
quantity credo because
firstly when these people with
large family and position of
birth [INAUDIBLE]
is not quite the same as
having two children.
And, number two, we also need
to know whether there was a
cultural and infrastructural
change.
[INAUDIBLE] changing attitude
towards girl's education and
more schools perhaps in rural
areas, for which, you know,
girls always tend to pick up
any opportunity much better
than boys do.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So that's an excellent point.
Let me start with the second
point, whether things changed.
That's the advantage of
comparing the relaxed versus
non relaxed.
Things probably would
have changed in
parallel in the two places.
The first point is
quite important.
Yeah, that's a bit late.
You can't show up at 2:00.
Sorry.
The first point is very
important, which is it's not
going from six to seven.
It's really going
from one to two.
And so there are two things
that are relevant here,
something which you also kind
of alluded to earlier.
One is we know that being
a single child is
not that much fun.
And maybe going from one to two
is good, but going from
four to five is bad.
So maybe we are not learning
about what we're really
interested, which is whether
families would reduce from
five to three by looking at
the one to two phenomenon.
So that's very, very true.
The second thing is all of these
children are girls who
are acquiring a brother.
And in a culture which is not
very favorable to girls, it
might be very good to have a
brother for a girl because
then the family is going
to send the kid--
I think that's kind
of related to what
you were saying anyway.
The family's going to send
the little boy to school.
Well, I might as well send the
girl with the boy anyway.
You know, instead of competing
for the resources, people
actually drag themselves.
You need someone to bring the
boy to school and there you
have the older sister.
That's kind of convenient.
So what we're learning from
this may not be actually--
I think we are learning that
having second child, for girls
in China, having a brother
was actually a good deal.
But whether this is telling us
about the quality quantity
trade off more generally, I
think you're right to be
suspicious.
AUDIENCE: I was just wondering
if there's selection bias.
So for families that have the
boy first time around, is it
possible [INAUDIBLE]
going on?
So if there are two children,
it sort of shows that you
value girls and would be more
likely to send them to school.
Does that make sense at all?
PROFESSOR: Right.
Yes.
You might have this problem.
And it would become problem if
the selection bias changed
over time, which is at the
beginning you have no
selection bias because
there is no abortion.
Towards the end you have more
and more abortion so the
families that still have a girl
are the ones who care
more about girls.
And that could be different.
So the thing is that it should
be different in a relaxed and
non relaxed area to
create a problem.
But if we are thinking that
the relaxed areas are the
areas where the bias was the
worse to start with then this
bias gets more and more chances
to express itself over
time because the abortion
becomes available.
And so that might also
create a bias.
So these two points are
both excellent points.
But they are different points.
One is that these might be a
bias in estimating the effect.
And yours is a point about the
interpretation, which I think
is quite valid.
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: This doesn't tell us
anything about average levels
of education again,
though, right?.
PROFESSOR: No.
This is all in differences.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So if girls get, say, a year
of education now where they
got zero years of education
before, the difference is made
up, whereas boys get, say,
10 years of education.
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
This tells you nothing
about the difference
between girls and boys.
This tells you that whatever
this difference was and
whatever this difference--
it used to be bigger.
Girls used to be more
disadvantaged in the relaxed
areas before the relaxation
happened and after.
AUDIENCE: I was just thinking,
if for boys there was no
change but boys were still
getting a high level of
education, this doesn't
really say anything.
But also if girls who were
getting zero education now are
getting one year, that also
doesn't seem that significant.
PROFESSOR: Right.
That is always like whatever
the outcome versus the-- it
turns out, I think, that in
China once they're born, it's
not that girls get very
different level of education.
So in that sense, I don't know
what the levels are.
But I don't think they're quite
different to start with.
So those are all excellent
points.
So all that to say that
maybe this is--
I agree with you.
In fact, I put [INAUDIBLE]
point on the slide.
Your other points were
also well taken.
Maybe that's not the
end of the world.
That's not the end
of the story.
This is definitely probably
the opposite of what would
have been expected.
I'm sure it's quite the
opposite of what
she expected to find.
So here is one more normal
example where it's not the one
child policy.
We are not forcing you to abort
the child that you don't
like the gender of, et cetera.
That's the ICDDR,B program in
Bangladesh where they provided
women in treatment areas
with regular access to
contraceptives, a community
health worker that visits
women at home regularly,
et cetera.
And they did this program
pretty constantly
since the late '70s.
It went on and on and on and
it's still going on today.
And that program was effective
after really insisting, very
effective in reducing the
number of children.
At the beginning it was
the most effective.
And then this effectiveness
went down, not because the
number of birth increased a lot
in the program area, but
because the number of birth
declined everywhere and
everywhere in Bangladesh very
fast during the period.
So at the end of the day the
effectiveness of this program
is a bit contested in that it
might just have accelerated a
trend that would have
happened anyway.
But regardless, it provides us a
good window into what is the
effect of a smaller family
because by 1996 women in
treatment area had 1.2 fewer
children than women in the
control area, out
of an average of
perhaps four or five.
So that's not an insignificant
change.
And there we are very much
closer to the type of
evaluation that you wanted to
see, which is if I reduce from
five to four, do I see a
difference in the outcomes?
Another thing the program did
is to provide very good
prenatal and postnatal
care to the kids.
Immunization, oral rehydration
solution,
et cetera, et cetera.
So one outcome that you don't
get is that kids are much more
likely to die in infancy.
That's fine.
But that may not be an effect
of having fewer families
because all these external
inputs were
given at the same time.
In 1996, a group of researchers
led by [? RAND ?]
went back to the area and did
a very detailed survey of
everybody living in both
treatment and control
villages, which is available
on the web.
So that is something
which people can--
if we want to do, like,
undergraduate projects or
whatever involving data, that
should be a good source of
data, very rich.
And first they look, of course,
is to look at whether
you find any affect on the
quality of the children who
were born during this period
in treatment area and in
control area, given that in
treatment they lived in a much
smaller family.
And what they find is no
difference, no difference in
height, no difference in weight,
no difference in
school enrollment, no difference
in years of
education, nothing.
So, again, here it's your most,
like, kind of classical
example of effective population
control of family.
A lot of the argument that you
guys discussed in the context
of the one child policy
can't really be made.
It's not Israel.
We can't say it's a rich
country that is able to
educate all these kids.
And, again, we find no effect.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I thought this was
really interesting because it
kind of ties into what
we've discussed
throughout the class.
I thought there has to be more
inputs into this equation.
So if students or parents are
more educated on the effects
of how their children could
potentially benefit from more
years of education then you
would expect if they reduce
the number of children, the
children would get more years
of education.
But if the parents weren't
necessarily educated on that
and didn't see the benefits
of it, then they just may
substitute away from the
research they would expend on
an additional child
[INAUDIBLE]
or--
I don't know.
Something other than the things
we're looking at here.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So one possibility is that
that's going back to the
argument we are making about
Malthus is maybe the pie is
actually not fixed because as
you have more children, well,
you're going to spend more
money on the children.
And as you have fewer children,
you're spending less
money on the children so that
what determines how much you
decide to invest in the child is
less the number of children
you have total but what you
think the returns to this
investment is going to be.
And another thing is that in a
lot of cases the investment
that we are talking about, they
are not so much money
because even in Bangladesh
school is largely free.
Maybe keeping a child, you know,
nourishing your child
is, of course, not free.
But it's not very, very
expensive compared to other
things you could do.
So maybe what we see is that
there is not so much of a
fixed budget constraint for
how much you can afford to
spend on your children.
But it's a whole family
constraint.
And what is determined in
children investment is less
how much money do you have or
how much time do you have, but
how you decide to allocate this
budget, which corresponds
more to the perception of cost
and benefits as we've seen in
all of our previous lectures.
So maybe you're right and maybe
we should have expected
that, and it just didn't
tie into things.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Maybe one way to look
at it is to look at the
effect on everyone else in the
family, like the parents.
Because, I guess, maybe a mom
would feed her children the
same as how many children
she has.
But, it would affect, like you
said, that overall budget
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So that is discussed
a little bit in the
chapter you read.
So what did people find when
they looked at the mothers?
AUDIENCE: The women in the
treatment areas ended
up with more jobs.
I don't remember if they
had [INAUDIBLE]
or not.
PROFESSOR: So in Matlab, what
you find is the mother in the
treatment areas are more
likely to work and
their BMI is higher.
And then there was this other
study from Colombia, which we
are going to see in a minute,
which showed a modest
reduction in the number of
children but also a lot of
effect on the timing of children
where people are
having children later.
And you find large effect on
women's education and woman's
job market participation.
So I think that's where you do
find it's exactly what you're
saying is happening, which is
that the pie expands and
contracts with the number
of children.
And, of course, something
else gives in.
But that's maybe the
mom for example.
AUDIENCE: One of the things that
was brought was the idea
that children are kind of used
like pension plans in a way.
And if you have less children
you save more [INAUDIBLE].
Has there been any studies
looking at difference in
governments, if it's more of a
socialist government and how
much social security
they give and then
relate that to fertility?
PROFESSOR: So it's
a great question.
And the quick answer to that
question is, surprisingly, no.
So if you've read the book
carefully, you notice that we
talked about the effect of
family planning and we talk
about the effect of culture or
social norms and stuff like
that, which I'm going
to do in a minute.
And then when we want to talk
about economics, we start
looking at the opposite research
is people who have
more children save less, or
people who have fewer
children save more.
So we switch the equation
suddenly, and therefore we
don't provide evidence that if
there is a Social Security
introduced or better insurance,
essentially people
have to fewer children.
We make the argument, but we
actually have no study that
directly supports
this argument.
We only have the opposite
studies, that people who have
fewer children save more.
And so that is likely.
That, I think, actually would
be a very nice study to do.
So that was for the first part
of the argument that large
families are bad.
And so by the end of whatever
literature there is right now,
we are yet to see any smoking
gun for that one.
The second part of the argument
is people cannot
control their fertility.
The not so nice version is the
cartoon I showed you where
basically they can't control
their fertility because they
are idiots.
And the nicer version, at least
the more politically
correct version, is they can't
control their fertility
because access to contraception
is difficult.
So let's test that.
What's the impact of making
contraceptive available on
reducing family size?
I mentioned that program
a moment ago.
It's a program that was
introduced by Colombia by a
young doctor.
Well, eventually he aged.
But in the beginning
he was young.
There was nothing before him.
And there was a big reduction
in fertility in Colombia
between the time that he
introduced his program and
when it was fully expended.
Fertility in Colombia
reduced from about--
you must remember that I showed
it yesterday-- seven
children per woman to about
three children per woman
between the 1960s
and the 1990s.
Now, fertility declined
in all of the
Latin American countries.
But it declined much
faster in Colombia.
Colombia used to be the country
in Latin America with
the highest number of
children per woman.
And it switched to being the one
with the lowest number of
children per woman.
I think it was the second
highest, and went to become
the second lowest.
So is it due to the program?
Of course, many other
things happened in
Colombia at that time.
So it may or may not be
due to the program.
So to look at the effect, young
professor in Stanford
named Grant Miller looked at the
way the program expanded.
And what he argued is that the
doctor had limited resources
and he didn't have a strong view
about where the program
should be put in place because
he wanted the program to be
put in place everywhere
anyway.
So whenever he had a chance
somewhere, he would go.
So what he argues is that we
can compare women who had
access to women who didn't have
access at various periods
in their life.
And then because maybe you don't
want to fully believe
this argument, he says,
well, that's fine.
Let's also look at how has
this changed over time.
So let's compare a woman who was
born later in the places
that got the family program
later to a woman who was born
earlier in a place that got
the family program later.
So the second woman didn't get
to benefit from the program,
and the first did.
And if you combine the two
sources of variation, you get
some idea of what was the effect
of the family planning
program, very much like the same
kind of strategy that we
used for the one child
policy in China.
So here you have the results,
first in log number of births,
which telling you it's 11% fewer
children per woman who
got family planning access.
Maybe it's easier to look at
this one, which is a number of
birth of kids born to a woman.
This is when you just
assume that the
program is randomly assigned.
So compare places which got the
program early to places
that got the program later.
This is controlling for inherent
differences by using
the expansion.
Now, it's also very similar, so
we can focus on this one.
And that tells you that having
access to the program when you
were young does have an effect,
very significant effect.
That's the t-statistic,
6.4% divided by 0.004.
The t-statistic is
through the roof.
That's extremely significant.
Shows you that a woman who had
access to the family planning
when she was 15 to 19 had about
6.4% fewer children.
So that's very significant.
But is it very large?
It's very, very small.
It's less than one tenths
of a child per woman.
So it's like that much.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: That's not a
big part of a child.
So it's not a very big effect,
even though it's very
precisely estimated.
The biggest effect are obtained
for teen, people who
got the program when they were
a teen and then a few when
they were 20 to 24 and 25 to
29 and then, of course, the
effect become lower because
after 35 most people are
finished, have completed
their fertility.
So what this tells us is, yes,
there is an effect of getting
access to contraception.
But it's tiny.
It's tiny, tiny.
It's like 5% of a child.
That's not a big
effect at all.
And, in fact, that corresponds
to a very small part of the
overall trend in fertility
reduction in Colombia at the
time, about 1/10,
maximum 1/10.
So this wasn't a
very big deal.
So was this unique?
It was not very unique.
Other program was submitted in
Indonesia which varies the
same type of idea, found
no effect at all.
But I already spoke to you about
the Matlab the ICDDR,B
program in Bangladesh.
Matlab is not only a software
program, it's also a place,
which is the place where
they did this program.
And in Matlab I just told you
that the fertility got reduced
by the program.
But there's two points
to make about Matlab.
Number one, it was a very
intensive program where
someone came to the house
every other week.
It's also a place where a lot of
women were in [INAUDIBLE].
So they were not allowed to
get outside of the home.
So it was harder for them to
access the contraception or
even to know that it
was available.
And this community health worker
was very dynamic, very
forward young women that were
going to everybody's family
and really trying to
convince them.
So you would think that the
Matlab program is something
else than access.
It's also changing people's
preferences.
That's point number one.
Point number two, as I was
saying a minute ago, initially
the effects were very large.
But then the effect in
differences between treatment
and control decline and decline
and decline because
everywhere in Bangladesh,
including in the control area,
fertility declined anyway.
So this is an extremely
expensive program, which by
the end of the day just
accelerated a trend that
happened in Bangladesh where the
reduction in fertility was
huge over the period and seemed
to have very little to
do with this program but
everything to do with other
things that were happening
in Bangladesh.
So it seems that contraception
plays a role but not a very
big one, maybe an acceleration
role, maybe a small reduction
in fertility, maybe
a timing role.
Of course, that doesn't mean
that you don't want to have
contraception available because
it is much nicer to
control your fertility with
contraception than without.
And the timing is
also important.
So I'm not here advocating we
should stop spending any
effort trying to make
contraception available.
Just to say that as a population
control policy,
paradoxically it's pretty
ineffective, which means that
if you wanted to control family
planning policy, you
would have to understand why
people make the decision they
make because it seems that they
are able to make their
decision and then they
will stick to them.
And if you make contraception
available, they'll use the
contraception to
stick to them.
And if you don't, they'll
anyway find a way.
So we need to go further in
understanding the decision,
which we'll do next time.
You.
AUDIENCE: Just a small thought
that maybe it's possible that
as long as the program's in
place, everyone heard about
it, and this brought the subject
of not having as many
children closer to mind, and
that helped anyway despite not
directly helping.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So we'll discuss that.
Except that I don't think the
discussion went much further.
In fact, there is a paper I will
discuss briefly next time
where the discussion
is very narrow.
It's like people from
you compound and you
discuss with them.
Even within treatment villages
we see the differences.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: I was
[? really flustered ?] in the
same thing.
Is that the kind of acceleration
that you're
talking about?
That, like, having this program
in place caused the
rest of the country to have--
PROFESSOR: No.
What I'm claiming is that if no
one had done any program in
Matlab, fertility in
Bangladesh would be
today what it is.
Matlab is a very small place
that technically didn't effect
the rest of Bangladesh.
But what happened is that
it was faster in
Matlab because of the--
that said, both of you make a
good point about social norms
that may have shifted in part.
I think Matlab was too small to
make any big impact on the
rest of Bangladesh.
So what it did is that people
were running a race in the
family reduction.
And the Matlab people arrived
a little bit earlier.
But they didn't arrive
much faster.
You had a point?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So we'll stop here and pick up
again on decisions next time.